I said earlier, that the reason that we need to put parentheses around 3w plus
12n, or the total amount of money that Grant would have gained from the orders
that have not been cancelled, was because this was one sum of money. We want to
subtract the whole thing, not just part of it. If we didn't have parentheses
here, then we'd only be subtracting the money that he would've earned from the
wipers that are now cancelled. But we would still be adding the amount of money
that he would have gotten from the nozzle orders that are now cancelled. But we
know that both of these sets of orders have been cancelled. So we need to make
sure that both of them are subtracted from the original sum of money. So let's
put those parentheses back. However, I don't really want those parentheses here
in the end version of this expression. So we need to get rid of them somehow.
Intuitively like I just said, you want to subtract both this quantity, 3w, the
money from the canceled wiper orders, and this quantity 12n, the money from the
canceled nozzle sales. So we want to subtract both of them, and if I get rid of
these parenthesis, I should just be able to switch this plus sign to a minus
sign, and have the expression that I want. This makes sense. Here's our
original amount of money, that Grant would have earned from all of the orders
that he had, and then we take away both the wipers that he's not selling
anymore, and the nozzles he's not selling anymore. That makes sense. Now, the
problem is simple, you've done this so many times before. You just need to
rearrange the order of the term, so that like terms are next to each other, and
then simplify. So first we rearrange the order of the terms, so the w terms are
next to each other, and the n terms are next to each other. And then you just
add they're coefficients together, and multiply it by the proper variables. So
87 minus 3 is 84, and the variable there is w, and 72 minus 12 is 60, and the
variable there is n. So here's our final answer, 84w plus 60n, awesome job.
That quiz had a bunch a steps in it, and some new material. So if you got it
even partially right, that's really great.